ah here we are the patreon folks you
guys are the real
deal thanks for tuning in thanks for
sending in questions we got packages we
got paintings talk about the painting
there sammy oh that we got the comedy
cellar there look at that it's beautiful
beautiful hand-painted that is
incredible yeah i love it they nailed it
too i mean it's dead on
we got a a
envelope from uh the lady who did it
actually oh this is it yeah give that a
tear wow this is a heavy envelope
nice little paper there well it's
weighted
waited
oh there's
little pictures
okay mushrooms
lady on a mushroom this must be her
artwork
all right she's something can you get
her name out
um oh these are a lot of naked ladies
well plugger the website is sadie
may stewart so
s-a-d-i-e-m-a-e-s-t-u-a-r-t
dot-com
her instagram is typical
it looks like
s-a-d-z i can't tell that's it
yeah
all right there we go art is meant to be
shared hey guys she lives by her credo
she gave us a song should we read this
it's long whoa
might be a little dirty
whoa
what is going on here
good looking lady i was picturing uh
some wheelchair-bound nut
who's got time to paint slapping the
base this gal is uh beautiful eyeballs
if i wasn't gay dudes you all rule thank
you for the ounce hey look she's holding
up the pick here
painting oh my god
great painting
thank you for the hours of entertainment
and laughter thank you for being so
interactive with your fans i really hope
you enjoyed the painting lots of hours
went into this piece and it's one of my
best it took me a while to decide what
to paint for y'all but no no but
now nothing makes more sense than the
comedy seller you both speak so highly
of this place and call it home i can't
wait to someday witness the magic that
takes place there i hope i did it
justice you did a great job great job i
also included some of my stickers for
you and your ladies all right all right
and for all salacious
too
more gifts coming soon i grew up in
lexington kentucky and wanted to send
some gems from the bluegrass
i smile every time you'll mention comedy
off-broadway such a special room it
really is a special it really is and
she'll be on the list when i go there i
threw my art website in here as well
mark i know you and me are wanting a
nude painting above the couch i'd love
to paint something for you all
naked ladies are my specialty if you end
up finding a piece holla
thank you
all right yeah please just mark with a
leaf over his junk
that's a big leaf thank you for both
for the infinite laughter stadium you
know what i gotta say by the way
you